back to square one myanmar back under
military rule
aung sang suchi who was held here under
house arrest on and off for two decades
is now again under military detention
despite a landslide victory in last
year's elections myanmar's generals have
seized power
most likely at the bidding of one man
commander of the army
minong leng the commander-in-chief his
term
expires in june he will have to step
down
uh he has too much invested in terms of
finances
in throughout myanmar and possibly some
even say
overseas enterprises through
military cronies and associates
aung may have won the nobel peace prize
for her struggle against military rule
but her defense of what the un called
the ethnic cleansing of the rohingyas
badly tarnished her reputation even so
with her gone there are now even greater
fears for them at the hands of the
military
the remaining rohingya in in rakhine
state are now really in danger because
this is the military who has everything
in there in their hand and their power
and they will do whatever they want to
do and they have been doing this
and they have evidence they have
experience to commit genocide and
and being not being accountable for what
they've done
there's been worldwide criticism of the
coup boris johnson tweeting
i condemn the coup and unlawful
imprisonment of civilians
including aung san tsuchi and myanmar
the vote of the people must be respected
and civilian leaders released in a
statement the white house says it
opposes any attempts to alter the
outcome of recent elections in myanmar
and will take action against those
responsible the u.n security council
meets in new york tomorrow
as outside powers scramble to try and
reverse the coup
and salvage hopes for democracy in the
country
the plight of san tsuchi and others now
being held in myanmar
is a huge test for the new biden
administration
and it's pledged to promote democracy
along with its allies
dominic waghorn sky news in washington